The funny thing about feminism
is that so many people
just don’t see why we need it.
Imagine a social experiment,
one that you should never ever do.
You have identical twin boys
and you call one Al and one Bob.
When they're five years old you
start giving them pocket money
for tidying away their toys.
Every week, you give Al a pound
and Bob 78 pence.
If Bob complains
deny it.
Tell him he's imagining it.
If he shows you evidence
and insists that it's unfair,
tell him Al is just that
little bit better at helping out.
Bob will probably start
to get his shoes on faster
and tidy his toys like a boss,
to show that he's as good as Al.
Occasionally, when Bob
has really excelled,
give him the full pound and say, "See
Bob, this just shows you can do it
when you put the work in.
You have to try harder."
When they're seven,
tell the twins it's time
one of them became
the toy tidying supervisor.
Interview them both.
Notice that Al comes to the interview
with an attitude
like he's got it in the bag.
Give the kid a high-five
and a fizzy drink.
Bob will probably over explain
himself nervously in the interview.
Do nothing to relax him
until he starts to look defeated.
When you give Al the job,
congratulate him
and tell him he's a born leader.
Give Bob feedback that
although he was well prepared
and you appreciated his
PowerPoint presentation,
there was a certain
something missing.
Tell him he needs
to be more like his brother.
That he's lacking a certain...
confidence.
On their tenth birthday, ask
the twins if they'd like some pets.
When they excitedly say "Yes!",
introduce them to Fluffy and Faloopy,
two adorable baby hamsters.
And tell them they are the absolute
equal owners of the fluff balls.
As they rush to stroke them,
explain that Bob will have to do 90%
of the feeding, grooming
and hutch cleaning.
Bob will ask how much
he will be paid?
Explain that hamster care
is worthless
but needs to be done relentlessly
without pay.
Whenever you see Al stroking the pets
say loudly to someone else
"Isn't Al a great hamster daddy?
Look at him babysitting
the hamsters,"
and make sure he hears it.
If Bob complains
about the extra workload
or falls behind
in his toy tidying role
say, "Well, that's the price
for having it all Bob.
Remember you’re the one
who wanted the hamsters."
Let's roll out this experiment, with
a whole generation of twin boys.
A few Bob's will get angry and grow
up to do better than their brothers
because they have something to prove.
A small number of Bob's will be
gifted with so much more natural
smarts or talent that they'll sail
past their brothers regardless.
As a trend though, 20 years from the
beginning of this social experiment,
twin boys called Al
will be more confident,
greedy for leadership roles,
sure of themselves
and convinced that their own
opinions are facts,
than their brothers called Bob.
It will be an Al's world,
not a Bob's world.
The funny thing about feminism
is that we can only see how
messed up that is
when it's two boys.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)